welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse an Avengers age of Ultron set up
infinity war an endgame in unappreciated
ways hidden in extended blue and orange
hue black montages Ultron really
contains the MCS most rewarding Easter
eggs some of which we found already in
priory visitations over the years also
some new revelations only visible with a
true frame-by-frame infinity saga
re-watched let's get to it
the film opens on the mine stone inside
Loki's scepter hurry in the opening an
infinity stone shot of the previous
Avengers that movie's enduring image was
the tracking shot linking the Avengers
mid-battle and Joss Whedon opens here
with a similar shot following the team's
charge on the Hydra base ending with a
full lineup frame together and then our
heroes eloquent opening words language
the Maximoff stern mutants in the comics
Magneto's children but the script avoids
the term mutants we have enhanced in the
fields 20th Century Fox used to own the
x-men and at the time they have their
own Quicksilver in the works so Marvel
can only feature the maxbox in this
movie if one they were never called
mutants - Quicksilver never joins the
Avengers in the movie and three the
maximov's connection the x-men and
magneto is never spoken of and you'll
notice the name Quicksilver is never
mentioned in this movie but Tony does
call Wanda a witch that little witch is
messing with your mind Tony now where's
the mark 43 suit upgraded from his
shattered prone mark 42 in Iron Man 3
and he's got satellite backup from
jarvis the central building is protected
by some kind of energy shield
this satellite deploys Veronica anywhere
worldwide and her name is actually a nod
to Archie comics with Bruce torn between
Betty and Veronica no not as jarvis gets
lots of love in this opening act Jarvis
take the wheel
yes as in jesus take the wheel Jesus is
my co-pilot foreshadowing Jarvis's new
form as the godlike vision Tony deploys
the iron Legion drone 3 here gets hit
with acid in the head
later we focus on this same damaged
drone face returning to Avengers Tower
and it ends up being these same masks
Ultron uses to make his first scrappy
body earlier films showed the gradual
evolution of Iron Man and capsuled
through specific stages boxes graphs
solid prototype 6 the upgrade Ultron
goes through these three stages of
evolution Fox crafts
solid prototype sexpot in one movie the
sokovia and boy in the protest kostol is
the same
Clint goes to save and Pietro dies
protecting from Ultron's gunfire
actually Pietro is opening words to
Hawkeye here you didn't see that coming
are the same as his final words you
didn't see that's coming cap shield now
has magnetic charges and he and Thor
reprised their accidental shockwave from
the earlier fight into this sick range
attack and they collab again later
Nats Hulk lullaby comes back hilariously
in Ragnarok Suns getting real low Suns
getting real low
Hulk reverts to banner here a process
that we've never seen them MCU before
but this film never outright shows him
hulking out Wanda put Stoney in a vision
recreated in his wormhole trauma and he
sees his endgame nightmare his friends
defeated cat's broken just like Thanos
doesn't in game and that woman near
Hawkeye hasn't ever been ID'd
but she's presumed to be like a shield
or a sword soldier Tony uses his
gauntlets to swipe the scepter
foreshadowing his future use of a
gauntlet to snatch and wield infinity
stone power to fix this mess Grand
Central is a new statue honoring the
first responders during the battle in
New York and we see the New Avengers
Tower T's in Winter Soldier here Maria
Hill waits last saw her interviewing
with Stark Industries later she leaves
with fury I'll come back for the way
Natasha worked under Tony but really was
Fury's operative mind if I borrow miss
Hill she's all yours meet Helen Cho in
the comics she's the mother to Amadeus
Cho a kid she needs to becomes the new
Hulk
I have speculated Amadeus Cho could have
been that valedictorian in Iowa City
that Sitwell mentioned Joe uses human
tissue tech this is the next thing Tony
your clunky metal suits are gonna be
left in the dust that is exactly the
plan Tony's Tech won't fail an infinity
war and leave him in Peter Parker's dust
but that dusting was actually part of
dr. Strange's plan Jarvis is Holograms
sphere is modeled on an orrery an old
tiny mechanical solar system model the
mine stones organic holograms shift
shape so the contrast here reflects the
opposing philosophies between vision and
Ultron vision sees order and chaos is
fitting within the universes clockwork
for his Ultron is more unstable than
erratic Tony Bruce uses this new AI to
launch Ultron as an answer to Tony's
nightmares I see a super
world peace in our time notice the
object holding this up here upright it's
actually just a clutch for a car manual
transmission and hanging up at the
foreground are banners elastic pants for
when he Hulk's out they're ready to go
over anything aren't they and Ultron
awakens
what is this what is this please from
darkness there's a spark of light evoke
in the spark of existence in the book of
Genesis much of Ultron's rationale is
Bible based the elders decreed it so
that everyone would be equally close to
God on this rock I will build my church
as Noah in his crash course in humanity
Ultron speed read the Bible without the
life experience to really understand it
James Spader emphasized Ultron's
relative youth despite his star flight
cattiness
he also erupts like a teenager a bunch
of times oh I'm sure that's gonna be
okay I'm sorry it's just I don't
understand
let's go frame-by-frame through this
Ultron speed read because there's a lot
of cool stuff but you should be able to
spot if you watch it slowly wrong okay
Ultron flickers past images of the
Avengers from past films as well as ad
age towered Starck they combine the
faces of Dominic Cooper and John
Slattery
maybe this is how he looked in the 1954
stark Expo its poster shows up here Nick
Fury shows up as deceased in that file
details how fury sent Barton to take her
out but they were able to flip her to
serve shield then we get some real-world
imagery peace figures like Pope Francis
Gandhi Mother Teresa and then war
European settlers versus indigenous
tribes world war ii the berlin wall the
vietnam war bosnia ultron views these as
mutually exclusive but as vision
observes later human history has always
been in a mix of order and chaos vision
later lectures this to them there is
Grace in their failings I think you
missed that that missed lesson is
actually here an overlooked quote from
Aristotle educating the mind without
educating the heart is no education at
all Ultron can only educate his mind but
Tony Stark's strength is heart power
Tony survived his heart attack Ultron
didn't and Ultron destroys Jarvis here
notice Jarvis's core twitches like an
eye in pain Thor drinks with some vets
including Stan Lee who did serve in the
Army during World War two and he utters
his signature sign-off
she'll she'll Natasha's cocktails are
read in black her signature black widow
colors and those two martini glasses
when stacked into end would form her
hourglass logo later we find out that
she kept a gun under this bar explaining
why she's working the bar here she was
on watch duty you know when people ask
me how I find Easter eggs hidden in
Marvel movie beverages it's because I am
drinking this stuff that opens these
eyes real wide and thanks to bang energy
for sponsor in this video every can of
bang is 16 ounces that's right now would
be 12 ounce kids here
it contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
it's sugar-free and as zero calories yet
[Applause]
it tastes great with over 20 different
flavors to choose from this labor is
black cherry vanilla all my favorite
flavors can abside it in one delicious
energy drink checkout bang on instagram
you can get 25% off your order at bang -
energy calm when you use the code new
rock stars 25 sorry to go take another
sip real quick all right back in it
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea kettle coffee
flavors you can also get clothing
fitness supplements all kinds of stuff
to be your best bang self thanks again
to bang energy for sponsoring this video
get 25% off at bank energy comm using
the code new rock stars 25 and follow
the emitter of bang on instagram at bay
energy dot CEO okay next the iconic test
of strength and that she knows before
Clint is calling back when he oversaw
for trying to lift the Samer in New
Mexico captain plunges it ever so
slightly setting up his big moment an
endgame
[Music]
right they later explained that cap was
always worthy but he faked it here do
spare Thor's pride which if you think
about it pre Ragnarok was really the key
to his strength
Ultron crashes the party I'm sorry I was
asleep
this idea of robot dreams returns later
I can read him he's dreaming it's not
too filled K dicks do Androids Dream of
Electric sleep adapted into Blade Runner
which explores the concepts of
antagonistic AI supplanting humanity
like Ultron aims to do and of course his
entanglement in strings is the first of
his Pinocchio motif the puppet 2 comes
to life but remains stuck in this weird
or official middle stage not quite flesh
the attacked leaves the Avengers shaken
with you ventures we can bust arms
dealers all the live long day but that
up there that's that's the end game
how are you guys planning on beating
that together we'll lose and we'll do
that together to this moment inspired
the end game title along with the
movie's themes of sacrifice and loss and
recovery age of Ultron might seem
incomplete to you but that is because
it's world building doesn't really get
cashed in on until later films
age of Ultron is best seen as the first
act of a three-act story setting that
problems that won't get solved until
later Ultron meets the twins under this
red cloak a nod to Ultron's original
Crimson cowl identity in the comics and
he declares everyone creates the thing
they dread people create smaller people
Ultron inherited Tony's aloof
personality so they make similar quips
do certainly it's your face Moeller
agents
nobody has to break anything clearly
you've never made an omelet he beat me
by one second The Avengers research
paper files probably caps since as we
saw in Avengers 1 and in Winter Soldier
cap prefers hard copies to digital ones
and they find the arms dealer ulysses
klaw a few years ago some eagle-eyed
redditors spotted claws belgian
great-grandfather was killed by two
chaka after trying to annex Wakanda in
the 19th century but looking again at
this now there are two big takeaways
here one for takaka to have been
deactivated years ago muscle even
continents have a longer life span into
a Belgian warlord in central Africa
the late 18-hundreds folks there
implying Klaus great-grandfather was was
based on or is associated with the
Belgian King Leopold ii who committed
atrocious war crimes in central africa
during his period which would have been
not far from where the fictional Wakanda
is located Bruce has profound respect
for this wakandan history la cañada whoa
whoa whoa condom his screen actually
shows the first two paragraphs of the
real-life Wikipedia entry on Wakanda and
this file name is labeled a 113 the
color its classroom that a number of VFX
artists nerdily sneaked into these
movies ultron buys cloth stolen
vibranium and cuts off his arm black
panther actually does this in the comics
and klaus sonic arm cannon takes on a
new form in the Black Panther film and
yeah this is all part of Ikeys weird
phase to amputation tradition where all
the club wanda give them all nightmares
Thor returns to Asgard with Heimdall
foreshadowing Ragnarok and infinity war
Oh a destroyer Odinson they see you
leading us to have Thor let's Asgard
burn and Ragnarok and notice that
lightning emits from his body without
his hammer
maybe signaling that is god of thunder
power comes from within and one of his
victims turns to dust just as those Thor
fails to save will in infinity war caps
nightmare takes them home to the 40s the
long-lost dance with Peggy the Wolves
over Steve
bingo home imagine it setting up his
homebound mission an endgame the band
here is the boy Thomas players Roy
Thomas is a comics writer who created a
vision Natacha returns to the Red Room
where the cave to be brainwashed or into
an assassin a backstory that will
probably see more of a black widow when
she shoots the target the splinters look
a bit red maybe the blood of the person
Natasha is really shooting here onto
Hulk vs Iron Man of Johannesburg so
great
Tony debuts the mark 44 Hulkbuster
powered by seven additional arc reactors
notice that Tony's heads-up display
zooms out to convey the extra layer but
Tony slips up you're stronger than her
you're smarter than her you're Bruce
Banner don't mention puny banner again
when they call Hulk banner
rages but when they call him Hulk or big
guy cooperates Tony goes for a KO to
sleep go to sleep go to sleep
remember banner did sleep through Tony's
story in Iron Man 3 and after this
banner will stay asleep for years
Tony tries to use some sedation spray
maybe a version of the tetrodotoxin B
serum that fury used to bake his death
and Winter Soldier into the toxin B
slows the pulse to one beat a minute
Benna developed it for stress didn't
work so great for him we found they used
for Hoch spits out a tooth just like
abomination did it gets real pissed he
swats away Veronica's backup tech back
at her to destroy both Tony has to drop
a building on him and around a year ago
some viewers spotted that Tony safely
implodes the building with Rockets
hitting it from the side showing how his
past collateral damage has affected him
and setting up his feelings on the
sokovia accords it ends with Hulk get
punched out of frame calling back his
great hit on Thor in Avengers on to the
Barton forum where Clinton reveals his
family and I love how Laura Barton looks
at cap when she says but I see those
guys those gods be gonna would cap and
Tony split logs foreshadowing they're
coming split Earth's Mightiest Heroes
pulled us apart like cotton candy
seems like you walked away all right
isn't that the mission isn't nothing why
we fight so we can end the fights do we
get to go home yeah it's the word hole
met triggers cap strange because in the
barn Flint's archery target which shows
up an end game has only the bull's eye
torn up because he never misses and Nick
Fury returns
artificial intelligence you never even
hesitated Fury's AI hesitancy would have
begun probably with a Korean Captain
Marvel who were governed by a corrupt
supreme intelligence
Tony responds look it's been a really
long day like Eugene O'Neill long he's
referencing O'Neill's a long day's
journey and a night a play about a
dysfunctional family collecting that
dysfunctional vengers family that he
needs daddy fury to set straight
some say theory in this movie is a
Skrull he's far from home suggested he
constantly scroll swaps here fury cuts
bread which some ingenious out there
mislabeled a smoking gun
because remember fury told Captain
Marvel toasters cut Dagon I can't eat it
the thing is bread ain't toast and fury
definitely cuts it horizontally not
diagonally the real question is why cut
a raw piece of bread didn't make a no
sandwich they're just gonna snack on
bread just pull a slice apart to see
when you give it actors busy work with
food over dozens it takes they start to
fail psychopath tests real fast
fury also says here we are back on earth
now yes the group's one extra
Thor ain't with them but fury is
referring to Tony flying the nuke
through the wormhole
so to be official here not a squirrel
Thor doctor subtle vague head to the
water of sight so that Thor can reflect
back on his nightmare okay
Thor sees four of the Infinity stones
reveals so far space mind reality power
gathering in a golden colored nebula
that you probably knows by now it looks
like the Infinity Gauntlet real quick at
the Nexus the background intern has very
take a photo of her with Tony I love it
stark and banner debates I'm gonna loop
I'm caught in a time loop this is
exactly where it all went wrong I know
it's not a loop it's tender line setting
up and game which fixes this dark
timeline with time loops that results in
the end of the line for Tony
Ultron's vibranium infused him a tissue
plus the mine stone plus Jarvis plus the
thorah of tap equals vision notice the
first human vision lays eyes on is Wanda
and printing on her like a newborn along
with the way he lovingly swoops in to
save her later sets up their
relationship explorance of war and
beyond visions name here comes from Thor
I've had a vision early on Thor's
nightmare he envisioned visions eyes
opening that connection allows vision to
wield Mjolnir where's in the infinity
stone that's not really clear Tony
upgrades with Friday named after girl
Friday in the movie his girl Friday a
well rounded office assistant but
notices other cards there's a Jocasta
Ultron's wife in the comics who turns on
him in joins the Avengers along with the
Takashi the chip that's in baymax in big
hero 6 and then we were trying to
sokovia
that man is playing solitaire that we
wouldn't notice but uh we did Ultron
turns the city into a gravity meteor and
cap gives his big rallying speech you
get hurt hurt him back you get killed
walk it off the camera cuts the Pietro
when he says if you get killed
yeah obviously death but it cuts to
bunda for if you get hurt hurt him back
and later when Ultron breaks her heart
by killing her brother she rips out his
heart I love it some years ago some
observant viewers on red had discovered
that the shape of the tear that she
makes in his chest matches the tear in
cap shield and Tony's nightmare earlier
other viewers noticed that back in
Wanda's final scene with Pietro they
left one Ultron century still
functioning and that's the century that
drops a city wall Wanda is avenging
Pietro vision discovers Ultron's final
century and notice this century's
severed shoulder and chest this is the
same drone that cap confronted earlier
on the bridge
see you'll never never what you didn't
finish and Ultron does get finished here
they're doomed yes but a thing isn't
beautiful because it lasts it's a
privilege to be among them you're
unbearably naive well I was born
yesterday
of course Ultron's death occurs off
screen and yeah later in homecoming
Peter Parker finds an Ultron head with
its red eyes glowing suggesting it could
possess Ultron's consciousness there we
made a few videos on whether this guy
could return but we see the new upstate
Avengers HQ Nazis Clint and Laura's baby
named Nathaniel Pietro Barton a pho
obviously for Quicksilver but Nathaniel
for Natasha with Barton honoring that
the way she honored him with her
necklace in Winter Soldier Fury reports
on an unidentified ship crashing in the
ocean we later learn Hulk took the
quintet two scars through what is this
ocean crash and why is it a name or
Easter egg I know Atlantis is in the
Atlantic Ocean the scratches in the
Pacific but it's all water Tony says bye
to cap you guys should take a page at a
Barton's book they'll pepper a farm hope
nobody blows it up a simple life you get
there one day
both setting up their endpoints for
endgame stark retires to a farm cap goes
home to his simple life and the final
shot shows war machine vision Falcon
Wanda and we just learned that there was
he deleted alternate ending with a
stand-in for Captain Marvel in this
lineup but cap blue balls us Avengers
incomplete ending for an incomplete
movie again act 1 of a three-act story
which later peaks with cap completing
this iconic line min game Avengers
Assemble
credits even show a story still in
transition an EVO Jima inspired statue
of the Avengers triumphant on a rock the
inverse of their rock of failure in
Tony's nightmare but then it goes right
into the foreboding stinger that kicks
off act 2 of this story which will be
infinity Ultron may or may not live on
in the MCU but on a symbolic level
Ultron represents the Avengers
blindspots their folly and trying to
encase the world in a suit of armor
their inevitable doom in that sense the
age of Ultron is an age that they will
live in for years to come how does the
age of Ultron rank for you in the MCU
that's definitely not fair to call this
the worst didn't seem film but as a top
a / bottom half comment down below with
your thoughts and you can join Future
infinity so I will watch Long's on disk
or by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash rockstars follow me follow me
rockstars and subscribed into rock stars
because folks I am coming back next week
with the most important MCU installment
[Music]